hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to inside now my voice
is hopefully gonna carry me through the
rest of this game and honestly I don't
want it to stop I know it's like
generally like what two and a half to
three hours I'm not on it wasn't sure
exactly but and that's usually how I
gave these things I just judge how long
they are to beat and I'm pretty sure I
can get through the entirety of this in
comic-con's time I just don't wanted to
end it so cool I don't know how close we
are at the end we may not be close at
all but hopefully some mysteries get
solved here ah we're not gonna make that
[ __ ] broke my legs broke everything
broke my will broke my spirits so why
couldn't I make that jump that seemed
like something that would been
incredibly is he only a fool would have
stopped him from doing it and a fool is
me so now really a mystery there alright
okay aerial roof buddy whooping ewwww
okay so gotta open that up I'm pretty
sure this is just a simple procedure of
opening this all the way up and then
just jumping over right up yep there we
go oh come on oh man I broke my back in
such a bad way oh man how did that how
did that not grab okay I did not grab
how can it how can it not okay sorry to
start this off with a little bit of
stupidity but I didn't get nearly enough
stupidity in the last episode I was too
good with naming names and therefore I
wasn't reflecting up to my full
potential of terribly stupid
maybe I just gotta like sync it up with
the swing so that I only go and it's
kind of swinging towards me in not away
so if I go now mmm there we go
yeah okay there we go figured as much oh
well this looks like a place where
people actually work again how how how
is it possible I want to know I mean my
goodness in the world with such strange
things everywhere you look you'd think
that there would be
logic in the life but alas that's not
how it goes ah running out of air
okay it'd be dude boot okay so we got a
double whammy okay I probably did this
in the wrong order [ __ ] come on dude I
don't know what you're doing so uh ah
okay okay I know what this is hey I know
what you do um I'm not too smart for you
but I'm Neverland I'm not even gonna
talk about how smart I have when I
started this off with the terrible
performance that I did but I'm still
wondering like why in the world is there
such a labyrinthian base why have we
deviated from the dystopian era and and
to be honest that dystopian era seemed
very recent like that was a recent turn
of events with everyone being herded in
and where did they come from they were
like recruiting people whoo hi uh don't
mind me what is wrong with you why do
you have cables sticking out from you
are you a cyborg Samantha Samantha uh
what are you doing I'm gonna run out of
air oh [ __ ] I wasn't thinking about this
for some reason oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy Wow
this ain't Pleasant where am I supposed
to go now I'm assuming stretch out as
far as I can on this thing go as far out
and then swim for my goddamn life here
we go hey listen oh boy oh boy oh boy
whooping hey not today not to do
and also want to know what she is but
there was a little clue that she had
wires coming out of her so she could be
a robot which would be a logical
explanation considering I don't imagine
that there's a lot of supernatural
occurrences going on in this environment
whoa boy oh boy oh boy I went the wrong
way I did not know I needed to go down
oh man I just wanted to cut away it
didn't want the people at home to have
to witness what happened to me I didn't
know that I was gonna need to get all
goddammit hi hi Samantha
hi you're looking lovely yeah is she
even if she's like plugged into
something that's so weird okay
yes so we're doing this so it's not too
far to the next row but it is a good
haul away from the next area yeah okay
so I need to get as much as possible I
don't know if it's gonna matter I am
dragging a bit on the ground he did ah I
don't know if we're gonna get much
higher good okay here we go here we go
wait maybe I can wait maybe I could oh I
don't need to it's a fool's errand
ha ha ha ha good thing i discovered that
right before i actually did it hit bend
it alright up we go up we go okay
alright so far so goo uh-huh now we're
gonna get it because I've got a much
better head start okay alright okay
oh not good not good ha ha ha ha ha
Samantha your time is up you shall not
get me oh ok where am I going now
oh good golly I don't know where I'm
going oh where did it come from where to
go get the [ __ ] out of Iran ha ha
ok all right we're good ok we're fine
everything's hunky-dory
okay so I gotta use this for some reason
and apparently the reason is not as
obvious as climb up on it and do the
thing okay so I'm going all the way out
to the hook here and yeah I'm not facing
the right way this hook is harder to
swing yeah hit oh boy uh hit the button
hit the button hit the button hit the
button hit the bunny bunny one hit him
on oh that's not the right button oh boy
I think all she does is just drown me
neither that's any better than the
alternative but you know I think that's
just all she does yes yes
yes yes okay so there's got to be
something to do with this let me yeah
let me at least face the right direction
in lesson oh there's a button up there
oh how many people were yelling at me at
oh I thought that was just a red light
oh well this is a thing where am I going
why am I going here cuz I can't exactly
jump up to it from the wall oh that is
the thing
haha okay so that's good
now she's farther away so that should
mean I've got more time before she gets
me ah yeah baby yeah okay I gotta get up
before I lose all my oxygen okay but I
got it where are was this sea level is
the question I mean obviously it's not
sea level system horribly disgusting
water but
okay anyway has anyone actually gotten
to see the video yet Rosa
am i still just illogical nonsense can
you can you do a thing there we go oh I
just got to push it
I got a Bhushan ah there we go now is
good for this not good not good not good
not good not good well I would be scared
if I didn't know you were already there
are you better be done you better be
done or else I'm gonna be very upset
with you
you better be done trying to kill me you
better be done with all your [ __ ]
I'm not gonna be able to open it this
way huh it don't work oh no my survival
is stuck I can't open this damn okay
anyway how about now Oh magically it
works who'da thunk okay so down here I
gotta like probably make another break
for it well this doesn't look promising
oh no oh no I need to depress it again
oh god oh god don't don't don't don't
don't
okay so I need to press it twice is the
big picture thingy all right I got it I
know what you need to need to do I know
I know a thing or two about knowing
things I know many things present twice
how would any would have known that it
without like going through that twice
okay point nope down hey hi Samantha how
you doing yeah my face is cool to grab
and strangle ah okay so you need to wait
a little bit longer than that timing is
crucial and I'm not good at timing
things okay so not instantaneous
but just long enough oh [ __ ] I wasn't
pointed in the right direction I don't
think that would have worked anyway I
don't think there would've been enough
time so she's got to be farther away as
the thing so there's got to be a way to
get her farther weapon up no there's not
oh yeah well oh I gotta hit the button
go back out of the water I think okay
that makes more sense because that
timing it down there is gonna be damn
near impossible so I gotta I gotta hit
the button get out of the water and then
immediately I got a Fisher over to the
other side then come back so I gotta hit
the button hit it get out of the water
out of the water or no no no no now now
now now now yes out whoa man that was
too close too close too close oh right
then I got a split splice over here oh
I'm over here now I'm over here yeah
yeah yes yeah yeah whoo whoa okay so now
I should just be able to press the
button carry on my way as fast as I need
you that's the idea anyway man I can't
believe this kid is still brave enough
to just constantly be going for it got
it got it got it don't get squashed
okay so hopefully that'll be the last
that I see of that little girl little
robogirl some mine through and then
hopefully you'll be able to make more
progress in here they have done a lot of
water levels this is me talking about
game design again but like they have
done quite a bit of water levels which
is something that's actually kind of
okay ah Samantha oh don't do it oh
please
Samantha Oh Samantha oh why well this is
scripted so I'm assuming the reason will
be expounded upon very soon
well am i dead
oh well there you go I mean good that's
not good
oh boy
Oh No
well this is dark
man
such cool visuals oh whoa what what is
that where did that come from
what is that
she been trying to help me all along
somehow not understand sure how okay
what was that what was plugged into my
chest oh man
still can't move the fish are very
interested though the fish are
incredibly curious about my body this is
when hello hi how are you what are you
oh your light okay better be just a
light better not be anything else but a
light hi who are you what are you what
is that over there what are you what are
you Oh what is that what is any of this
is that it as prize is a decomposing
body part oh man whoa hey oh wait nope I
guess I'm okay apparently now for some
reason I have the ability to breathe
underwater perpetually maybe I'm slowly
being turned into one of them slowly
being transformed from the inside out
who knows what I'll be at the end of
this road will I even be human or will I
be different inside I don't know I'm
trying to be profound and it's not
working but this is fascinating so
there's some sort of like biomechanical
type device that fundamentally changes
people it's the yellow lights the yellow
lights are kind of that idea like the
yellow lights on the helmet the yellow
lights on whatever the hell changed me
in that way so there is something to
this I just don't know what yet I'm sure
it'll be revealed at some point very
soon but for now it's just an odd thing
I was supposed to drown and that little
girl Robo
did something to me whether
intentionally a whoa hello did buddy
whether intentionally or not did
something to me that looks like a baby
or a fetus on the wall back there it
looked like a fetus for a second there I
wonder if that's it whoa whoa whoa whoa
hi
whoa hi whoa hi what are you are you
alive what the hell okay I goodbye what
the hell I was just weird
that's so weird uh it's an
understatement to say that this small
journey of this child has changed him
but it's just fascinated by the way I
have I have noticed the numbers I I have
been noticing the numbers I just didn't
know if I needed to call them out for
any particular reason but like I
remember seeing a lot of twos and I'm
seeing that three I'm wondering if I saw
a lot of threes before am I supposed to
go to the lighter am I supposed to
explore a bit let me go down just in
case because you never know what's down
here besides black inky death
but other than that there might be
something of note ooh like what the hell
is that uh hello
okay alright then alright okay
don't know what the hell this doing what
am i doing Oh oh it was body parts
that's what I saw oh no oh no oh no oh
god oh god oh man hold on tight lids
will believe oh boy
oh that got close oh man
okay alright go for it or go up I don't
know which is better at this juncture
man go wherever the body parts came from
that's so weird
oh man that's so weird oh this is
horrifying it's poor kid
I mean maybe lucky kid cuz now he can
breathe underwater and that's cool I
guess but this just seems where they
dumped all the bodies oh man my guess
you know what I guess all this is alien
invasion it's probably what it is the
big thumpy thump that's an alien alien
machine trying to keep us all suppressed
that's what of [ __ ] should've done this
shouldn't have done this shouldn't have
done this I [ __ ] up [ __ ] up ah mah
mah damn it goodbye goodbye little Billy
goodbye alright so gotta wait until it
goes after it can't be too easy gotta go
away then come back so yeah this must be
some it's some external force that has
gravely interrupted normal society in
this world [ __ ] add dammit goddamnit I
was cranking the wrong way on the yank I
hate when I crank the wrong yeah
so it's either aliens or some horrible
government experiment gone wrong
somebody somebody wait I go the wrong
way I went the goddamn wrong way again
god damn it
uhh such a fool go down click the down
button this time marking move you can
remember 19 names or 18 considering you
didn't name the dead body what's up with
that you insensitive prick I don't know
I don't know ok I'll be fine oh I don't
know what this is for
were they Diggy so I guess I'm just
hopping from one to the other
ah also I love the way light works in
this one light is a very important theme
in this game that I've seen so far no
I'm not sure how correct I am on that
assumption but light definitely though
the way light works in light being like
a guiding light and light helping I'm
gonna dive in Oh nailed it nailed it I
don't need to breathe or just stupid
okay where am I going why am I here was
I not supposed to go down was I oh I
might have just wanted to jump in and
then immediately pop out of it
that probably was a good idea that
probably helped me a lot
okay I'll do that yeah dad that seems
more like yeah that's a good idea
okay so yeah but lighting is a bit of
everything because most of them light is
very monotonous and most of this game is
very cool tones it's very gray very blue
those types of what is happening wait a
minute okay back the [ __ ] up - goddamn
steps into reality zone again and you
explain to me why there's [ __ ] water
and floating bodies in the ceiling I
wasn't ready for that I'm not ready for
that I don't I don't know what's going
on here I don't understand it I don't
get it
I don't want to get it I want to go home
I'm okay I'm done with this it's no good
no boy no no boy no okay so I think
there's some semblance of a button up
there and then there was a hatch where I
could go into the water
that is a floating body up there that's
probably quite a few floating bodies and
some other things that I don't want to
understand there's just a lot of whoa
okay this dude
yep that's what I wanted why did I want
to do that to exclude me from the rest
of the universe
it just seems bad this just seems bet
why is that light burning on right now
where my wall [ __ ] where am I now was
all this oh is this where all the
money's located can I have some hit me
okay good job kid you're getting
stronger every day who needs food whose
knees oxygen uh
ah okay wait so all I did was close the
hatch but did that do anything I don't
think it did because if that closed the
hatch unless it opened another one then
we've got a problem yeah all I would
have done I closed that hatch
oh I didn't see this thing was this
hozier huh yeah they didn't really do
anything yeah all I did was close the
hatch so what benefit did that do we got
another puzzle on our hands
we got a puzzling puzzler I mean I'm not
one to like want to jump to aliens you
know I'm I I don't want to make that
conclusion here but I'm still very
curious as to why anyone anyone would
have the motivation to enslave an entire
population for forced labor I mean it
may be humans but you know I'm just I'm
just trying to find the motivation
behind anything or anyone trying to do
that like what would the purpose of that
would be and it seems like this entire
world has been built around this idea
even though it's very desolate like
these are nondescript environments like
these are nondescript you know
quote-unquote machinery environments you
know what I mean so it's not really
obvious what it is or what it is not
know what I mean okay but anyway we got
one of these what do we do this do we
use it
do we take it with us nope can't take it
with us so where do we use it this is
gonna launch me into the ceiling and
kill me that'd be amazing okay why why
oh geez but why can I break that thing
and what's the purpose of this device
since the device makes no sense I could
crush myself I could do that Oh
ah I know what I need to do I need to
time it so I get it off the rail because
I can have it I just need to time it so
it goes away
how am i holy [ __ ] dude
whoa what the [ __ ] man
idiot it takes him aromatherapy man you
need to work out some aggression cuz
holy [ __ ] okay so that doesn't help so
if that doesn't help then there's
something else that this needs to be
used for but where oh I know what it is
it can launch itself duh can launch
itself so if I put it on this incline
here it'll launch itself at an angle and
then be able to get up there don't hit
me don't hit me whatever you do don't
hit me he's waiting for you
bloob nice nice bro nice good job man
good job you're really killing it out
there
you're doing a great job I'm really
proud of you okay so now I open this
this makes more sense so I just got a
groove I just got it whoo oh there we go
I just got to get this in time it's oh
it's up there and that's why I go around
I got it
ha okay we got it
okay we are succeeding and all of our
endeavors yeah it's really interesting
because these puzzles are like
fundamentally the same but they flow
together very well like I do appreciate
the flow of it is interesting
well-designed one could say one might
say but I won't say that right but I
just hope I get some answers soon
because I've been playing this for a
while now and I'm still I'm more
confused than when I started this game
like I thought I'd slowly be getting
some answers because it started out
relatively normal what with all in the
woods with seemingly normal people not
great normal people but you know
seemingly normal and then it just got
really weird over time like with this
whole ceiling situation with the
and the what-have-you so I don't know
what to think and I'm gonna press that
button up there and then note oh by the
way remember I mentioned that I had to
wipe off the spit off my monitor the old
spit that's collected over the years I
can already see specks forming from the
new generation spit that's gonna chew in
the hole so yeah it's uh it's not good
not good bro okay so I just need to hit
this oh did that light was that light
always on that light was always on right
good hit okay we did it we did it what
did we did we whatever it is we did it
hello what do you do why is there a
radio up here why would there be a radio
up here it doesn't make a whole lot of
sense oh thank you good thing that was
automated or else I wouldn't have known
when I was gonna be doing it so what did
that do do I have to follow the line
follow the yellow line but it kind of
just ends there huh
what could that have done look at that
have done oh I guess oh that was a bonus
oh that's the bonus oh those are the
bonuses I thought that was something
that I needed to do it didn't seem
obvious that that red button was hidden
so I get I know what I need to do I need
to get into that watery area for some
reason to go upside down I don't know
why it is but you need to take this over
there and launch it on top of the other
launcher thing so it launches you doubly
under the launching launch did that make
for advanced did that make friends okay
so all I gots to do is drag this back
over here onto the thing double do the
thing then we're golden
okay so crank this up crank this up hold
this over get on top easy peasy
and this is gonna go yep there we go
hobo's key oh the worms the worms are
back oh my god the worms are back how
does all this work I do not know but the
worms are back oh oh oh oh that's not
good oh you have no head stop that so
dance reminds me of soma now like you
know the ideas in soma where you know
machinery taking over people like that's
that's coming coming back in big ways
right right right about now and
especially the prevalence of water
oh hello I don't know what okay do I do
it do I need do it oh boy oh boy why did
that fall down what was that what was
that maybe I go through there no maybe I
gotta pull the other thing out there's
another one on the other side yeah there
is okay
oh I don't know what this is and I don't
know who built it and I don't know who
that guy was having a bad time over
there he got bumped his rest was
disturbed it also weird so weird so
weird
okay so anyway I'm all out of time for
this episode I'm probably gonna finish
this up in the next episode I can't wait
to see what is going on here or maybe
not maybe there's more to it than I
think there is but we're almost there
either way so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always see in
the next video bye bye
Mona who's that who were you I saw that
those are saying oh my god
you